looking over the mcu's blockbuster
history it's pretty clear that the
franchise has a villain problem but
despite that we've actually seen some
fairly compelling criminals cause
trouble for our heroes
here are all the villains in the marvel
cinematic universe ranked from worst to
best
in the dark world curse leads a prison
riot helps malekith sack asgard and
kills thor's mother friega
he also leads the battle against thor in
the film's climax beating the thunder
god senseless with his brute strength
but even with all that
curse is little more than a forgettable
monster with no personality
fenris hello's enormous wolf is an
undead beast who tries to finish off the
asgardian refugees toward the end of
thor ragnarok
to the wolves credit the menacing
green-eyed monster definitely looks cool
but sadly veneris really doesn't do much
after hella animates her beloved
familiar he just sort of hangs out and
looks mean while the death goddess
interrogates a crowd of scariness
guardians
in the final battle fenris tries and
fails to kill the hulk
on the one hand it's nice to see another
bad guy from thor's rogue's gallery fit
into the film
on the other hand it seems like the only
reason fenris is included is because the
hulk needed something to tussle with
during the climactic final battle
laffy is a powerful force in thor's
corner of the mcu but we never really
see much of him in action
king of the frost giants is the
biological father of loki he has super
strength and ice powers but he's still
no match for the sneakiness of his own
son
loki manipulates events to get lauffy to
attack asgard and thor
but just as laufey is about to kill odin
loki takes out laffy instead killing the
frost giant king and making himself look
like a hero in an unceremonious end
aldrich killian turned out to be the
a-list bad guy in iron man 3
with brant and sabin shaping up his
little more than b-list versions with
the same powers
both are given their superheating and
healing powers by the extremis virus and
they both attack tony stark throughout
the film
but neither is a match for iron man even
when he doesn't have a suit
scorpion is a pretty big deal in the
comics but in spider-man homecoming not
so much
his most notable actions are complete
failures first when an arms deal is
interrupted by spider-man and then later
when he tries to get the sinister six
going in prison before being shut down
by the vulture
basically he's just there to make adrien
tombs look cooler by comparison and when
you're not as cool as the vulture it's
safe to say you screwed up pretty bad
somewhere along the way
it's easy to forget but yes batroc the
leaper is part of the marvel cinematic
universe
we meet the french mercenary during the
opening ship hijacking sequence in the
winter soldier
we get a breathless fight scene between
captain america and batroc with cap
accepting batroc's challenge for a
hand-to-hand fight without a shield
batrock holds his own though cap
eventually knocks him out but hey
at least he's a little cooler than this
version spider-man homecoming gave us
not just one but two shockers
we meet the first shocker jackson bryce
as he's wielding a shocker gauntlet but
after the vulture kills him the weapons
pass to hermann schultz
schultz looks to be our main shocker in
the mcu and he gets one epic fight
against spidey before being sidelined
shocker jumps peter as he leaves the
school dance attempting to follow the
vulture
the villain sends spidey flying through
a school bus knocking his web shooters
off in the process
so why does shaka rank so low because it
wasn't even spidey who took him out
it was pete's pal ned who grabs a web
shooter and hits shocker
distracting him long enough for spidey
to web into a school bus
baron von strucker led the experiments
on loki's scepter that created
quicksilver in the scarlet witch so he's
definitely important
but all anyone really remembers about
him is his immediate surrender to the
avengers during the opening of age of
ultron
no surrender
i'm going to surrender in the end
strucker was just another hydra goon
cut off his head and nobody really
noticed when the destroyer shows up in
thor
it makes full use of every moment the
destroyer's giant powerful arms and legs
can crush or stomp just about any
opponent
and if they don't kill you its laser
blast probably will we saw the destroyer
kill a few frost giants then laid waste
to a small town in new mexico and loki
sent it to earth hunting thor
still it was no match for thor when the
god of thunder regained his power and
overcharged the destroyer
ending the attack credits sam rockwell's
unending charisma for iron man 2's
justin hammer not showing up at the very
bottom of this list
as far as credible villains are
concerned justin hammer is an absolute
joke he runs an arms manufacturer that's
a rival to stark industries
except everything hammer builds falls
apart the first version of the war
machine armor is basically a bare bones
iron man suit outfitted with a ton of
hammer weapons which works just about as
well as duct tape and accessories to a
car
to summarize sam rockwell is great
justin hammer still kind of sucks though
dr samuel stearns doesn't actually ever
call himself the leader which is his
villainous identity in the comics
but the incredible hulk isn't exactly
subtle about the eccentric scientist
destiny
the last we see of him he's on the
ground as the hulkified blood he's just
pumped into emil blonsky drips into an
open wound on his head
if a hulk sequel had come to pass we
would almost certainly have seen tim
blake nelson return as the psychic and
super intelligent leader
nelson is perfect as an obsessed
scientist who doesn't care much about
the consequences of pursuing his goals
across
ethical lines while he never actually
turns green on screen he shows plenty of
signs of a moral compass in need of some
fine tuning
he clones a whole room full of banner's
blood without banner's knowledge or
consent and he has no problem with the
notion of turning blonsky into
abomination
and of course in his final moments in
the movie he's seen smiling when any
sane person would be horrified
in the incredible hull general thaddeus
thunderbolt ross spends the entire film
trying and failing to kill bruce banner
and for much of the film he's a
relatively one-dimensional military bad
guy
interestingly however ross is one of the
few characters from the incredible hulk
to resurface later in the mcu
he became the u.s secretary of state in
captain america civil war
pushing for the adoption of the sokovia
courts and even made cameos in infinity
war and end game setting him up for even
bad or bad guy stuff in films to come
in an effort to capture the hulk
humiliated soldier emil blonsky hits
himself with an experimental version of
the same gamma stuff that makes hulks
and hulks
except it doesn't turn him into another
hulk instead he becomes the abomination
a monstrous one-note creature that looks
like a rotting troll
yawn he lives through the end of the
incredible hulk and is apparently in a
jail cell somewhere
dark elf malekith had almost no
personality and basically existed as a
freaky looking dude trying to get an
infinity stone and thanos already does
that way way
better it's a shame because on the
surface malikith is extremely formidable
he even stages a surprise assault on
asgard itself breaching the city's
defenses and later sets his sights on
earth he put up a heck of a fight
against thor in the final act of the
dark world though the god of thunder
still prevails
mickey rorick's whiplash was one of the
many problems in iron man 2 despite some
admittedly awesome action scenes along
the way
whiplash never feels all that
intimidating at least after that epic
attack at the monaco grand prix
he's motivated by a vague kind of boring
backstory and teams up with justin
hammer who we've already established
kinda sucks
and then there was that odd obsession
with his bird tannelier tavonne better
known as a collector has a remarkably
low-key career as an mcu villain you
might understandably question whether
he's really a villain at all
look carefully and you can see that he's
pretty darn evil as early as his first
appearance in a thor the dark world mid
credit scene
we learned that one of his goals is to
collect all of the infinity stones but
probably just for bragging rights not
conquering the universe
but a closer look at his expansive
collection reveals a whole lot of
unwilling prisoners
we're fairly certain that if the
collector were ever given a more active
role in the mcu he'd earn a higher spot
on this list
there's something intriguing about the
way he's been on the periphery of the
narrative's most cataclysmic events
mystery surrounds tyvonne including the
mystery of whether or not he's still
alive
when obadiah stain decides to take out
tony stark while starks on an overseas
tour in the first iron man film he
contacts the terrorist organization the
ten rings led by raza to make it happen
raza keeps stark captive and proves an
intimidating villain
at least until stark builds his first
version of the iron man suit and makes
short work of raza's soldiers
raza was savvy enough to survive and he
tracked down straight bits of stark's
armor and tried to cut another deal with
stain
the problem stain was more savvy than
raza and used a sonic taser to paralyze
him and kill his men
despite his unceremonious ending raza is
still technically the first villain we
met
in the marvel cinematic universe and a
throwback to the simple days of the mcu
korath has a small but memorable role in
guardians of the galaxy which provided
one of the most memorable moments from
the movie's opening scenes
hey you know what there's another name
you might know me by
star-lord who
star-lord man though star-lord gets the
better of him korres still puts up a
heck of a fight
he also manages to reacquire the
infinity stone along with nebula which
sets up rone in the accusers near
world-ending attack on xandar
without korath ronin would never have
had the infinity stone to begin with so
he certainly served a purpose
even holds his own against drax the
destroyer for a while at least until
drax rips out the cybernetic implant in
his head
killing him hey at least he went out
fighting andy circus actually does an
extremely entertaining job with ulysses
claw in both age of ultron as well as
black panther which gives us a
believable version of the claw we know
from the comics and cartoons
a character who still has the potential
to come back after his death as a dude
made of sound waves
hopefully the mcu will resurrect this
classic comics b-lister for future super
villainous action
walter goggins is a genuine delight
every time he shows up on screen and his
appearance in ant-man and the wasp is no
exception
sure sunny birch doesn't do much
compared to the likes of killmonger or
thanos but he might be one of the mcu's
most comic bookie villains ever
as a dealer in illicit technology birch
is a character that
like the vulture operates on the fringes
of a universe filled with magic hammers
and alien technology
the difference is birch is the kind of
sleazy mastermind who rolls around in a
white and gold suv conducts his illegal
business in broad daylight
and commands an army of nameless
motorcycle riding henchmen
birch is the perfect character to have
around to reinforce the idea that
there's more to this world than
shakespearean gods and magic space rocks
she might not have been the big bad and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 but the
golden goddess aisha was able to cause
more than enough trouble for star-lord
and his team
the leader of the powerful sovereign she
commands a fleet of remote-controlled
warships that come within one shot of
taking out the milano following an
extensive chase
moreover the post-credits scene revealed
aisha seems to be responsible for
creating adam warlock a major player in
marvel's cosmic universe and someone we
expect to meet in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3.
if nothing else that makes her more than
worthy of a slot on this list
the chitauri basically served as cannon
fodder against earth's mightiest heroes
in the final hour of the avengers
even still they are a massive alien army
led by those
positively terrifying gigantic dragon
ships that tore through manhattan
their eventual humiliation
notwithstanding the chatauri were more
than formidable enough to push the
avengers to the brink in their first big
screen team-up
and when they return for their big final
battle and end game their only strength
seems to be in numbers
and they were defeated just as easily in
captain america the first adventure
artem zola's appearance is basically
just an easter egg
in winter soldier however the setup of
having zola around for the first movie
pays off in a cool way
he might not be a robot with a camera
for a head and his face on a giant tv
screen built into his guts like in the
comics
but what winter soldier's big reveal
lacks in robot bodies it more than makes
up for by making him genuinely creepy
anyone familiar with marvel comics knew
some kind of villainous turn was coming
from mordo and doctor strange
while he spends most of the film as
strange's ally the angry sorcerer
abandons his allies after strange makes
his bargain with dormammu
after the credits we see mordo become
the nemesis he's long been in the comics
declaring there are too many sorcerers
in the world
he's bound to be a challenging
antagonist in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
plus he's played by chuatel at geoform
the oscar-nominated actor is not only a
superb performer but he's particularly
great in villainous roles
the black order are perfectly
serviceable henchmen for infinity war
they manage to hit that sweet spot of
being threatening enough to present the
heroes with a challenge but they also
provide additional room for the action
so that it's not just 40 people trying
to punch thanos at the same time
ultimately they're not so threatening
that they overshadow the actual villain
of the piece
each of them is distinct and visually
menacing especially ebony maw
unfortunately most of them don't
actually get to do much other than lose
so that's a bit of a drawback
in guardians of the galaxy ronan was a
religious zealot who co-opted the power
stone to continue his crusade to wipe
out xandar
but even without one of those awesomely
powerful ball balls he's still a heck of
a warrior
after all he laid waste to drax the
destroyer without even breaking his
sweat
he also had the guts to stick it to
thanos then actually walked away from
the mad titan without much consequence
the guardians were no match for ronin
individually but luckily star-lord was
able to actually control the infinity
stone with the help of his team his half
celestial powers and some sweet dance
moves
all of those things together and
star-lord was able to blast the bad guy
into a bolivian
ant-man's daring cross spent his entire
career trying to duplicate hank pym's
shrinking formula but when he did it and
created the yellow yellowjacket combat
suit he didn't realize his copycat
formula was actually messing with his
brain
making him dangerously unstable that led
to a villain who was not only
dangerously unhinged but got some really
cool fight scenes
the best of which was on a child's play
table ant-man and the wasp's super
powered villain ghost has a lot going
for her
visually her flickering and phasing
through objects is some of the coolest
looking stuff we've seen in the mcu
it's even better in the fight scenes the
shrinking and growing stuff is fun but
pitting that stuff against a completely
different set of powers makes for some
pretty compelling action
since she seemingly reforms at the end
of the film we're obviously meant to
like her
she has a sympathetic backstory as a
victim of hank pym's egotistical past
but at the same time we're also supposed
to like hank so his part in ghost's
backstory still involves him ultimately
being right
none of this is too surprising marvel is
full of bad guys doing the wrong thing
for the right reasons but it does feel
pretty clear that ghost was shoehorned
into ant-man and the wasp
rather than building her more
organically still the effects are great
and hannah john commons performance
captures ava's understandable bitterness
and desperation effectively
die hard comics fans know surtur is a
major villain in thor's world
in thor ragnarok however he appears only
in the opening act and destructive
finale that's not to say he's not
important to the story
in norse mythology the word ragnarok
points to the apocalyptic battle between
gods that results in a world destroyed
by fire
while serger is indeed the monster all
asgardian sphere
thor and loki summoned him to invoke the
ragnarok prophecy
this defeats hela but at a price his
attack decimates asgard
crumbling the city in the sky to dust
when marvel asked annette benning to
play a villain in captain marvel they
probably didn't open with
you're going to be a giant green
disembodied head with a bunch of gross
tendrils floating in some kind of goo
that would be an accurate description of
the character's physical appearance in
the comics
but instead of the bulbous floating head
captain marvel's creative directors
chose to represent the ai that rules the
kree empire as a kind of psychic
projection
everyone who communes with the supreme
intelligence sees someone different and
in carol's case the intelligence appears
as their mentor marvel
as viewers we spend a lot of time in
captain marvel thinking the scrolls are
the bad guys once the truth is revealed
it's yawn rog who's the most visible
villain
perhaps in the future we'll see more of
the cree ruler giving the supreme
intelligence a chance to get a better
spot on this list
red skull easily stands out as one of
the most original and terrifying baddies
in the marvel cinematic universe
in the first avenger he commands his own
hydra branded nazi division
complete with tesseract powered weapons
and has his own version of the super
soldier serum
making him cap's physical equal he
vanished while trying to harness the
power of the tesseract space stone but
his surprise return as the guardian of
the soul stone and infinity war
only served to remind us how great he
was so many years ago
he might have just been a disciple of
dormammu but casilius was plenty
intimidating in his own right a highly
trained sorcerer who went rogue
left the ancient one's order to try and
take out the masters of the mystic arts
and nearly succeeded
in doctor strange casilius manages to
destroy two sanctums put the ancient
one's forces on the robes and chose his
prowess with magic and a few excellent
fight sequences
luckily a quick thinking strange manages
to turn the tables and win the day
the tinkerer is exactly the kind of
character that the mcu needed for the
same reason that he was exactly the kind
of character that the comics needed
someone who builds all the gadgets the
bad guys used to fight the good guys
he's certainly not the focus of
spider-man homecoming but phineas mason
is the kind of quiet bad guy who makes
the mcu feel just a bit more real
every great ruler needs someone beside
them to carry their melting stick
in thor ragnarok that job goes to topaz
the sadistic and unforgiving right-hand
woman to the grandmaster and she's a
perfect match for her eccentric boss
while he delights in his games and
acquisitions topaz stands nearby ready
with his instruments of torture always
eager for the grandmaster to melt people
unfortunately for the grandmaster topaz
does not survive ragnarok and crashes
while chasing bruce banner thor and
valkyrie during their escape from sakhar
topaz's service to grandmaster is
clearly not forgotten
in one of marvel's shorts we see that
the grandmaster has built a modest
shrine to his former assistant in his
new los angeles apartment
of all the impressive things about
spider-man homecoming one of the most
notable is just how many characters the
film pulled in from the comics
and the best minor villain appearance by
far is absolutely aaron davis known in
the comics as the prowler
in the film he's hilariously and
thoroughly unimpressed by peter parker's
enhanced interrogation
what happened to your voice what do you
mean what happened to my voice i heard
you by the bridge i know what a girl
sounds like
i'm not a girl i'm a boy
it's one of the best comedic scenes in
the entire mcu but what really makes it
special is davis's mention of his nephew
as comic readers know davis nephew is
miles morales who eventually takes the
name of spider-man
as far as villainy goes davis doesn't
accomplish much beyond a failed arms
deal
hinting at a future of the mcu that
includes miles though that's awesome
sure the ravagers aren't all villains at
the end of guardians of the galaxy
plenty of them sacrificed themselves to
save xandar
but in the sequel we see a darker side
of these mercenaries
when taserface takes over yondu's
ravagers everyone still loyal to yondu
is rewarded by being injected into space
as their former comrades laugh and wait
most of them are also more than happy to
abuse poor baby groot
and of all the survivors only kraglin
refrains from trying to kill yondu
rockets and groot as they escape
as villains the ravagers don't
accomplish a lot and without someone
like yondu or nebula supporting them
they don't provide much of a challenge
to the heroes
but while they may be cannon fodder they
still give us a lot of laughs
their well-deserved beatings provide
some of the most fun sequences and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2.
brock rumlow started out as a member of
captain america strike team and winter
soldier eventually revealing himself as
a hydra agent when the attempted
takeover began
he managed to survive and resurfaced
during the opening fights in civil war
where he went toe-to-toe with both cap
and black widow before blowing himself
up in the event that ended up driving
the avengers apart
for a villain that's a pretty good way
to go dormammu
is one of the biggest villains in marvel
comics and surprisingly the mcu actually
kept the extremely powerful ruler of the
dark dimension relatively close to his
comic's counterpart
doctor strange's trip to the dark
dimension was practically a steve
ditko panel brought to life dormammu is
so powerful that doctor strange had no
chance of hurting him so he had to
outsmart him to save the world trapping
the villain in a time loop where
dormammu killed him over and over
until he was forced to bargain for his
freedom it makes for one of the most
clever finales in all of the mcu
and lands dormammu high on our list of
favorites
after one final explosive tussle with
gamora nebula joins the side of the
angels and guarding into the galaxy vol
2 but that's not true of every version
of nebula we meet
in fact it's indirectly because of
nebula that thanos gets to wage his
final battle against the good guys in
endgame
when nebula goes back in time to 2014 to
help get the orb the nebula of that time
becomes aware of her the 2014 nebula
isn't reformed
she's still loyally killing anything and
everything her father tells her to
as well as harboring murderous jealousy
towards gamora 2014 nebula is pretty
tragic
even when she's confronted by her heroic
future self the 2014 nebula sees no way
out
she clearly wants to be different but
she ultimately dies because of her
refusal to change
even though the proof that she can
change is literally standing in front of
her
when marvel signed robert redford for a
superhero movie you knew it'd be an
interesting role
and his turn is alexander pierce
delivered he's introduced as the
well-meaning secretary of the world
security council and old friend of nick
fury though it's eventually revealed
pierce is actually a hydra agent leading
their infiltration of shield
pierce shepherded the program designed
to create the network telecarrier system
everyone is fighting over in the winter
soldier
he also planted bombs and the name tags
of the other security council members
which he uses to brutally murder them
when they challenge his takeover
he stayed evil to the end too uttering
hale hydra with his dying breath after
nick fury put two rounds into his chest
now that's a villain
ben kingsley's character in iron man 3
wasn't actually the real mandarin and
they all hail the king one shot short
suggested the actual bad guy could still
be out there
waiting to make his move but that faked
mandarin still gave us the chills at
least until it was revealed that he's
really just an out-of-work actor named
trevor slattery who can barely be
trusted with a six-pack of beer much
less a gun
still though it loses some luster by the
end the mandarin presented in the front
half of iron man 3 is one of the
scariest baddies in the mcu
it might have been a ruse but it was
effective and you'll
never see me coming
when thor is suddenly marooned on the
junk planet's car he comes in contact
with a grandmaster
in the comics the grandmaster is just an
immortal dude who loves playing games of
any kind
but in the hands of jeff goldblum the
grandmaster becomes one of the weirdest
and funniest
characters in the mcu here's hoping we
get to see a lot more of him in the
future
oh maybe not as much as he wants us to
on any other world i'd be like
millions of years old but here on sakhar
you have to respect where it all began
and jeff bridges obadiah stain aka iron
monger
set the tone for the villain to the mcu
in the first iron man film
bridges stain is positively slimy
betraying tony stark and inadvertently
setting his entire hero's journey in
action
so really we can thank stain for kicking
off the entire mcu
when his assassination attempt on stark
in the desert bales stain eventually
dons the massive iron monger suit to try
and finish the job himself
a lot has changed since iron monger
stalked the skies but his final fight
with iron man had a brutal messy feel
that really let you feel the hate
staying head for stark and it still
resonates even in a world with heavy
hitters like thanos prowling around
james spader's chilling voice brought
absolute terror to the metal menace that
was ultron
with a near endless supply of robot
bodies and a design that had comic fans
geeking out
he exemplifies how technology can be our
greatest scourge though
ultron does it with a wit that only
spader can provide verbally sparring
with the best of them
like any great villain ultron also has a
real motivation for his dastardly deeds
looking at the facts ultron's final
determination that humans and
superheroes are what make the world such
a dangerous place makes its own twisted
kind of sense
the most amazing thing about helmut zemo
in civil war is that he's just an
average guy with no real plans for world
domination
he's just a man who wants revenge for
the death of his family and he's wise
enough to realize the best way to take
out the avengers is to set them against
one another
yes his plan does require a few big
leaps of movie logic but it was
refreshing to see a villain like zemo
brought to life in the mcu
he's a great reminder that it doesn't
take world smashing superpowers to give
earth's mightiest heroes a run for their
money
iron man 3 is one of the most polarizing
movies in the marvel cinematic universe
featuring an epic fake out that reveals
guy pierce's aldrich killian is actually
the villain behind a mysterious rash of
bombings and terrorist attacks sweeping
the globe
his secret weapon extremis a versatile
technology that first showed up in the
iron man comics and is reimagined here
as a way to super heat one's body and
literally regrow
limbs killian's particular skill set
makes for one of the most technically
ambitious fight scenes in the mcu
it's sometimes hard to believe any
villain can truly go toe-to-toe with
tony stark but killian made a heck of a
run
peter quill's search for his father was
a key part of guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 a journey that brought him face to
face with kurt russell's ego
who's as bad a dad as they come ego is
one of the most powerful villains in the
mcu right up there alongside
thanos himself ego's essentially a god
who wants to literally become the
universe by replacing
all other life and russell sells it so
well that you really understand where
ego's coming from
even if he's a psychopath who's killed
hundreds of his own children in his
quest for power ego redefined the
concept of daddy issues
of course i have issues that's my
freaking father
mysterio isn't the best villain in the
marvel cinematic universe but he might
just be the cleverest
after 10 years of movies inspired by
comics the mcu proved with endgame that
it was its own distinct version of the
superhero universe
a series of alternate surprises led to
mysterio with a promise of a multiverse
that could take thanks to the next level
and then we find out that it's all just
one big con instead of being the way
forward mysterio ties everything back to
the very first iron man movie and is one
of the many things that made far from
home the perfect epilogue to the
infinity saga
in a universe of world destroying
monsters the vulture is decidedly street
level in his approach but that's exactly
what makes him work
the film's writers tweaked his backstory
to make adrian toombs the father of
peter parker's teenage crush in
spider-man homecoming
and he takes the girlfriend's angry dad
trope to a whole new level
the effects team did an amazing job with
his armor and appearance with
vulture looking positively terrifying
and inhuman when he's stalking his prey
we've never seen thor face a villain
like hella the goddess of death and any
of the other
mcu films much like loki before her this
asgardian villain is someone audiences
will immediately love to hate
as soon as odin passes away hella
appears to the brothers and presents her
plan to take her rightful place on
asgard's throne
to prove her point she easily crushes
thor's hammer the truth is eventually
revealed that hello once acted as odin's
executioner leading the asgardian army
to victory over all nine realms
this secret history elevates hella to
epic villain status
eric killmonger essentially has a
superhero's origin
his father is killed in front of him his
royal heritage is denied to him
and he uses those tragedies to motivate
a relentless dedication
training himself to the peak of his
abilities before seeking vengeance
that setup is a whole lot closer to
batman than it is to ultron
when you add in the fact that killmonger
specifically wants to address a
continuing history of racism
it's hard not to admit that he makes
some pretty good points
even if he's right though his goal is
dominance rather than leadership which
makes him a true ideological opponent
for t'challa
it's one of the things that makes their
final battle in which they're both in
nearly identical black panther
costumes so good they're reflections of
each other both committed to fight for
their ideals without compromising who
they are
there's a reason marvel studios chose to
use loki as an ongoing villain for the
avengers he's one of the most compelling
calculated and charismatic villains ever
tom hiddleston is so good at being bad
that marvel opted to keep him around
long after his bid for supremacy was
foiled at the hands of earth's mightiest
heroes
he's still no match for the hulk
but who is oh wait we know who
thanos is the villain of the marvel
cinematic universe
there's been a lot of character work put
into the cinematic version of thanos
which is especially impressive
considering that most of it is shown to
the audience in infinity war
a movie that's also juggling story arcs
for dozens of other characters at the
same time
through it all he's shown to have the
same quality that all the greatest
villains share
he thinks he's right he's the hero of
his own story
the only one who can step up and save
the universe from itself and is willing
to sacrifice whatever he needs to in
pursuit of that goal
in the comics thanos has been referred
to as the ultimate nihilist but the
mcu's version is the exact opposite he
believes very much in what he's doing
which makes him even more compelling
and more dangerous check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one